[Applaudissements]
avec nous bien sûr arrête c'est fini
quoi et alors c'est terminé toi et moi
non si non je décide de reconquérir
ah oui mais j'ai même demandé l'aide de
là pour ça quoi c'est que satisfait
petits plats dans les grands mon petit
je veux pas de place vous pouvez nous
filer un petit coup de main à mettre un
peu une ambiance de reconquête schia il
existe je vais la faire je vais la faire
un cap et cap et à bercy
baba il existait d'autres façons de vous
quitter
quelques éclats de verre aurait
peut-être pu vous aider dans ce tte pmp
il a voulu te pardonner les erreurs
qu'on peut faire atrous et met d'accord
le petit camille le soir souvent te
réclament est presque comme une mère tue
le bordel protégeait il tu as volé pedro
vous auriez pas dû le partage est à bout
de mot de rêve
je vais critères
il tape tout comme un fou comme 1 bat
babouches en chocolat comme un lourd
comme un roi comme une mairie kenzo
sahara
mais
la roquette si la règle et amis merci
d'avancé
merci la citoyenneté amical là on
reprendra on reprendra en bonne et due
forme en fin de semaine 1 face à devant
les parents exactement